and these guys have faced josiah gray at
23 years old 6-1 190 last start on the
11th against the pirates received the no
decision and that's 10-7 loss five runs
on just three hits
and the payoff pitch garrett will take
the base so a good lead off walk for
garrett hampson i think
buddy's been talking a lot about walks
and being able to earn those the on-base
percentage huge especially for the top
of the rockies order
and that's inside so back-to-back walks
this has been his big issue
rocky's new in scouting report i'll
bring up charlie blackman who's been
running a marathon since 2011. so
runners on first and second
and charlie's going to fire at the first
pitch and rightfully so that ball
off the wall is going to bounce in fair
territory off the warning track and soto
is going to throw it in
with a run scoring so charlie blackman
leading things off the scoring variety
with an rbi double cj does have a homer
on the trip did that in philadelphia
first pitch to him
is sent in the air to
center field this should be deep enough
to score rogers thomas makes the catch
he'll throw the ball into third
sacrifice fly for c.j krohn
rogers scores to make it two to nothing
herman marquez of course making his 30th
start of the season
now the pitch swinging up base head into
left field toward the line shaded that
way was helya the left feeler on it
quickly soto will make the turn and hold
it first with a single as he let that
pitch get deep they were in the over
shift
yadiel 27 rbis
up the middle a rocket
story gets it throws off the bag it gets
away so a run will score and the nats
answer on the board
most probably a hit and a throwing error
and it's a 2-1 game gabe ruiz the sixth
net to bet in this setting
[Applause]
ruiz to the gap in the left center the
nats have tied it so who has scored
first in this game take your pick
it's two to two perfectly placed a two
out double in the two out rbi scoring
josh bell
the line is moving a nice answer by the
dance after the rockies put up a two
spot in the top of the first
and there's a grounder
to trevor story so marquez gets through
it and gets through it clean one two
three
and it's still a 2-2 game out in d.c
yadiel playing way out toward left
center
had him reaching taps one on or near the
plate gray's got to be quick and he does
it perfectly
good athletic assist two down
swing and a miss on a big uncle charlie
downstairs
what a great pitch
got him again
three strikeouts trevor's story swinging
twice yeah both times with the slider
not picking it up if it ain't broke
don't fix it he's gonna see some more of
those next time up too beard ruiz big
hit first time
[Applause]
and he was ranking in the minor leagues
and
now he's starting to slow things down
here as well you'll love it when a young
player is using the ballpark and that's
what he's done twice
off the pitcher's glove thank you very
much
it's going to turn that into a base hit
that thing was going right to second
for at least one out marquez got a piece
of it and it's two on
one down here in the fourth
garcia fell behind o2 first time pulled
the grounder to crone at first
oh that ball's well hit left center
tailing away from hampson he'll pick it
up on a hop ruiz chugging home the nets
are on top and the kids are all right
tonight
top of the order lane thomas
garcia started then stopped that ball
slammed out deep left center
c
u
later
homer number five is annette
and lane thomas a leadoff guy
has driven in 22 runs in just over 29
games
here's the 3-2
swinging blasted to right center field
toward the gap long chase for hampson
and blackman looking up and this one is
off the wall escobar on his way to
second as hampson fires it in and it's
cut off
so escobar bangs one off the right
center field fence for a double
ball in play and story
will go to first krone picks it
and the inning is over all nine came up
to the plate
and force forward big home run from
thomas lane
got him
first out top of the fifth strikeout
number four
95 buy him two k's in a row two walks in
the first led to runs let's see what can
happen here with brendan rodgers coming
up with two outs
football's hit out to left field and
hernandez chasing it back does it have
room it does and what a catch from
ashton goudeau
another road homer for brendan rodgers
the two-run variety to get the rockies
back in the ball game
[Applause]
and he'll roll one over to garcia good
to get that quick out
but a pivotal top of the fifth for the
rockies
and trevor out to right field and that's
gonna bounce in fair so trevor trotting
into second for a stand up double
[Applause]
and mcmahon will find a gap so he sends
one out to left field and coming home
strong is trevor story and the rockies
continue to inch back in this one six to
five
it's just a real good piece of hitting
for story he doesn't even pick up stu
call he just did it on his own
sam fouled out and struck out against
the starter gray
crushing the 2-2 let it fly out in d.c
as the rockies
will take the lead on a two-run homer
from sam hilliard
they'll base head
ball crossing right in front of juan
soto so he stops at second seventh
inning the big guys set the table yadiel
hernandez next one two to yadiel
and this one
high and deep to left hillyard checking
his surroundings halfway on to the track
two runners are tagging
and that's a productive out in a close
game soto the third bell followed him to
second
[Applause]
hit out to center field
garrett hampton tracking it and he'll
make the final out for the rockies they
had traffic and got out of it to hold a
7-6 lead ryan is six for 24
with two career homers against jody's
shaseen
and he'll turn on one and knock it right
down the left field line
may have to hustle for a couple here
hilliard the throw he is safe at second
and ryan zimmerman has a pitch hitter
12th base hit of the year
righty righty now with escobar who's one
for seven career against yolice jose
and there it is
zimmerman coming home
el cetis has tied the game
and they're loaded with one out and now
josh bell in the spotlight
[Applause]
slow roller
tag
safe
nets take the lead
as fp said one to the runner at first
soto all over the middle infielder no
way the rockies could be quick enough to
turn a couple betty black's gonna go ask
second base umpire nick marley what he
saw looks like everything buddy's
bringing up is being met with a no from
nick
elias diaz has been no stranger to
heroics this season
there we go diaz deep and that ball is
gone
elias diaz coming through in the ninth
inning on the road
18 homers for the rockies catcher we are
all tied up again in nationals park
that'll bring up brendan rodgers
line drive to left field that'll land
and there is the go ahead run
brendan rodgers coming through on the
road
that's a good start
a three-hit knight
and twice
using the other side of the field
that's down by a run base head
adams on the move heading for third
ryan zimmerman refuses to let this game
end tiger back to the top of the order
lane thomas devas looking to end it for
the rockies
while on the ground to rogers he'll go
the easy way and colorado feeling good
on this road trip
you